good afternoon everyone my name is dr.
Miller and the SCP were going to be
looking at today is SCP 1281 object
class safe special containment
procedures the remains of scp-1234 to be
kept at outpost 1 2009 monitoring
equipment will be installed around and
within the entity in case it should ever
become active again any proposal for
study that might damage SCP 1281 must be
routed through command description SCP
1281 is a biomechanical entity found in
the Kuiper belt during standard
containment of SCP 2362 SCP 1281 is
roughly teardrop shaped with a flattened
section designated as the bottom of the
entity it measures 12 metres from end to
end and is 11 meters in circumference at
its widest point opposite there is a
significant bulge which is believed to
store the majority of scp-1257 disc
shaped structures on SCP 1281 surface
that are presumed to be receivers for
various forms of electromagnetic
radiation as well as lozenge-shaped
capsules of unknown purpose several
areas on its surface are broken
suggesting more appendages were once
present biological components appear to
have grown over a mechanical frame
evidently designed to live in deep space
when observed the entity seemed to have
difficulty coping with temperatures much
warmer than the Kuiper belt its surface
temperature was 50 Kelvin when first
found
SCP 1281 was apparently once capable of
interstellar travel but most of its
systems were damaged by an unknown event
that left it stranded dating methods
suggested to have been at least 1.3
billion years old though much of that
time was spent dormant the entity was
almost entirely dormant when it was
found
the only signs that it was active were
faint lights running along its surface
observation and experimentation showed
that these were in response to radio
waves it apparently had been collecting
signals for some time but no sign of
other functions could be detected until
foundation assets approached at which
point it began broadcasting it was able
to break foundation decryption in less
than one hour at which point it began
broadcasting binary signals in an
attempt to communicate starting with
extremely simple mathematical concepts
however after a report was transmitted
back to earth it stopped broadcasting
for several days the temperature of its
dorsal bulge heated by five kelvin
during this time apparently from
processing the information
this is interview log SCP 1281 1 we have
a signal coming in activate the
text-to-speech thanks hey can you hear
me how we are the SCP foundation we are
know we call ourselves humans a CP 1281
shut down for approximately four hours
the temperature around us EP 12 81 s
dorsal bulge eated up significantly to
about 60 kelvin the foundation team went
into standby in the event that SCP 1281
became hostile while a message was
transmitted back to earth asking for
further instructions the o5 counsel
advised caution but instructed dr. bloom
to continue attempts to communicate with
an eye to bringing SCP 1281 into a
containment solution
this is interview log SCP 1281 2 in the
outer reaches of this solar system
beyond its planets we call it soul
you've been in space for about 6
revolutions around the galaxy s CP 1281
shut down for seven hours this time the
heat was more severe up to 70 Kelvin and
it seemed to cause some damage to the
biological components of the entity all
5 counsel advised against deception as
it could complicate long-term
containment solutions and because the
odds of the species that created SCP
1281 still being both able and willing
to initiate hostilities were deemed low
interview log SCP 1281 3 i'm afraid i
don't know the stars would have looked
very different back then I must perform
my function I must complete the mission
so long ago stasis wait for further
instructions wait for rescue rescue what
is your mission what is are you the
Masters No we are humans my mission you
are not the Masters I must SCP 1281 shut
down for slightly over 10 hours the
surface of its dorsal hump reached 85
Kelvin to the detriment of its organic
tissues
this is interview log SCP 1281 4
this is our harbinger it brings good
tidings we will be dead when it reaches
you our planet is dying we do not have
time to save ourself we only have time
to ready ourselves and to send a message
we have seen the signals from those who
came before us they were different and
we still don't really understand them
but if there were those who came before
there may be those who come after it is
in this hope that our harbingers travel
one has found you and learned your
language so it can relay this message
please listen the galaxy is dark and
empty and cold it's been is inevitably
toward death you will die too one day
perhaps you will have longer than we
have we hope so but one day you too must
vanish before that time comes you must
light the darkness you must make the
night less empty we are all small and
the universe is best but a universe with
voices say nine here is far greater than
a universe silent one voice is small but
the difference between zero and one is
as great as one and infinity we waited
too long our voice is gone - echoes find
others while there is still time
make a course and if this finds you too
late and your time is also passing
please send this message on so the next
voice can speak against the darkness SCP
1281 went inactive for 15 minutes before
its final communication interview long
SCP 1281 5 that was the message yes you
don't know but you just translated it
for us I was made with the words but I
don't know what they mean it was a very
important message a good mission was
important knew it getting tired almost
done don't
mission is done bring two hot cooling
broken harbinger are you master yes did
I do well
yes harbinger well done SCP 1281 systems
appeared to be shut down entirely as it
radiated heat the temperature dropped
back down to 50 Kelvin it was brought to
outpost 1 2009 for study over the next
several months its tissues began to
decay and no further activity has been
detected note dr. bloom was reprimanded
for emotional involvement interfering
with the containment of an anomalous
object and was placed on administrative
leave
okay this slight sad one today but as
you'll learn working at the foundation
days that contains something happy that
don't involve scp-999 don't really exist
anyway on that note thank you for
listening if indeed you still are and
you're all dismissed
goodbye
I would like to give a special thank you
to Bob government Jim's Sabha arbiter
Sewell
dr. bright Darius Tom Maximus Decimus
Justin day Oh philia gray derp Nam Alex
Hill and jayvo Jack Corey Barker I run
in and dr. Proctor thank you all so much
for your support
it's greatly appreciated if you would
like a special thank you at the end of
each of my videos on some other cool
stuff as well visit patreon.com forward
slash the Volgin thank you
you